all right let's do this check this out
on September 19th 2008 Republican
Congressman Spencer Bacchus made a trade
that was effectively a bet that the
stock market would drop his trade meant
that for every percentage point that the
NASDAQ dropped his investment would go
up by 200 this is what's known as
shorting the market and it was actually
a brilliant bet because take a look what
happens over the next four days
oh and this is when he sells nearly
doubling his Investments it was an
amazing trade it was almost as if he
could see the future wait what's this ah
the day before he made this trade
Bacchus was sitting in a room in a
private meeting with the top officials
of the U.S treasury and fed the meeting
was so secret that everyone had to hand
over their phone before entering the
room the people that Bacchus was meeting
with were the ones who were in charge of
making sure that everything was under
control in the U.S economy but this was
September 2008 and things were not under
control this could be the most serious
recession in decades so in this meeting
Bacchus was told that quote it was a
matter of days before there was going to
be a meltdown in the Global Financial
system let's talk about the speed with
which we are watching this Market
deteriorated we're down over 16 okay so
that explains why he was able to make
This brilliant trade he knew when the
market was about to crash because he had
Intel from within
but what's crazy is that Bacchus is
short on the market wasn't breaking any
rules it was totally legal luckily we
have Financial disclosures
all of the stocks that lawmakers buy and
sell
public information so we can see
who's making trades based on Insider
information and we've used all of this
information to make a list for you a
list of the lawmakers that we see as
some of the best investors in our
country and in this video I want to
explain how their Insider knowledge may
help them make the best bets on Wall
Street there's all sorts of insider
trading happening in Congress
the American people should know that a
member of Congress is never leaving a
classified briefing and calling their
stock broker
so we in the west love a good free
market buy sell and invest as you please
but for certain people who have special
Insider information about the economy we
have rules to stop them from gaming the
system with their knowledge we pass
these laws like a century ago they're
called insider trading laws insider
trading insider trading basically they
prohibit people from selling an
investment like stocks using non-public
information this includes tipping this
info to other people who then go buy the
stocks based on that Insider information
and an Insider is anyone who is an
officer or director or 10 stakeholder or
anyone who possesses Insider information
because of his or her relationship with
a company this could be like the
daughter of a CEO who has Insider
information because she talked to her
dad around the dinner table about what
the company's going to do next so if
you're the CEO of Microsoft you're not
allowed to sell a bunch of your stock
the day before you release an earnings
report that shows that your company's
profits are down which will likely
trigger like a drop in stock price a
free market needs to be a fair market
too so that the Insiders aren't always
the ones with the knowledge to make the
best trades okay so while insider
trading laws are very clear when it
comes to business Executives there's a
group of people in our society to whom
these rules kind of don't apply
lawmakers historically Congress has had
no restrictions when it comes to trading
stocks for most of American History
insider trading laws that affected CEOs
didn't apply to members of Congress
lawmakers hear loads of private
information they sit on committees where
they investigate and talk to businesses
all the time this stuff affects the
economy and thus the stock market and a
lot of it is private they know this
stuff before the rest of us do and yet
for most of our history here in the
United States lawmakers have been able
to buy and sell stocks with very little
restriction and that is why this report
exists
This brilliant study recreates all of
the trade that Senators made over the
course of four years in the 90s and
found that consistently these Senators
had abnormal positive returns like way
better than some of the best investors
in our country a study of data from the
1990s showed Senators trades
outperformed the market by 12 percent
per year that crushes investment Guru
Warren Buffett who only managed to beat
the market by 2.5 percent that decade
okay so either these civil servants are
just like super Savvy investors or as
the study suggests the Senators knew the
appropriate time to buy and sell their
Common Stocks like we're all kind of
guessing when we're playing the stock
market everyone's guessing what's gonna
happen next if you kind of know what's
gonna happen next because you're like
privy to the information about the
economy you can play the game a lot
better
thank you better help for sponsoring
today's video I'm a massive believer in
therapy therapy has transformed my life
and I believe that everyone needs
therapy
um I don't think it's like a thing that
is for people who have clinical mental
health issues though it's obviously
useful for that but all of us who live
and have relationships and feelings and
good days and bad days could use a
professional to speak to and learn about
how our minds work and learn how to see
and understand our thought processes
that's what therapy is betterhelp is a
platform that makes therapy more
accessible to people finding a therapist
is difficult when you have to like call
around see if it works with your
insurance go to an office wait better
help use this technology to get rid of
all of those barriers what you do is you
sign up you take a quick quiz and then
better help matches you with someone in
their massive network of like tens of
thousands of licensed professional
therapists that you can start
communicating with
immediately like within a few days you
can do a video call you can do a phone
call you could even just do texting back
and forth regardless of how you do it
you are communicating with a
professional therapist and you're
starting your journey towards increased
mental health which is something I
deeply believe in often it takes a
moment to find the best therapist so the
best part is if you get matched with a
therapist that isn't a good fit for you
you can change immediately for no cost
and they'll just find you someone else
in their huge network of therapists
until you find the right person it's
really a game changer for making therapy
more accessible there's a link in my
description it's betterhelp.com Johnny
Harris clicking that link helps support
this channel but it also gives you a
discount to try better help out you get
10 off your first month so you can try
it out at a discount see if it's a good
fit for you thank you better help for
sponsoring today's video Let's dive back
into our list if we were trading stocks
based on Insider info we'd go to prison
they don't go to prison this happens out
in the open and then as banks in the
stock market were collapsing in 2008
lawmakers once again made headlines with
their surprisingly successful and
suspiciously timed trades in 2012 The
Washington Post did a big investigation
into this and found that in the lead up
to the 2008 meltdown at least 34
lawmakers from both sides of the aisle
changed portions of their portfolios 166
times within two business days of
speaking with Administration officials
so many of these lawmakers are making
loads of money while the economy is
melting down around them when asked
about their Shady transactions lawmakers
such as John Boehner quote declined to
discuss their transactions after this
blatant display of Insider knowledge it
became more and more clear that
lawmakers were using their knowledge to
enrich themselves and it was not a great
look at a time when millions of
Americans were losing their life savings
and jobs houses it was the worst day on
Wall Street since the crash of 1987. oh
but remember it was still legal they
weren't breaking any rules it was their
right to do this but the pressure
mounted and in 2012 they passed a law on
themselves we have an act of Congress
look at this 112th Congress passing laws
to regulate their own greed I love this
I love this the idea that everybody
plays by the same rules is one of our
most cherished American values oh and
look at the name of the law this is the
stop trading on Congressional knowledge
act the stock act pretty clever this law
bans Congress from buying and selling
stocks based on Insider information and
requires them to publish all of their
trading activity which is one reason why
I have all of this paper they're like
now required to disclose all of their
stock trading great 2012 they passed the
law problem solved right well no not
according to our reporting despite this
law we still have a list that I'm now
about to show you
this is the list of all the lawmakers
who went on to continue to make Savvy
trades in the market all while still
being totally included to private and
privileged information about the economy
okay first up we've got the financial
disclosure of Republican senator Richard
burr from North Carolina
[Music]
in January 2020 before any of us really
knew that the world was literally about
to shut down Burr was the chairman of
the Senate intelligence committee on
January 24th he together with a bunch of
senators were briefed on secret
information about how bad the
coronavirus pandemic really was about to
get and according to this unsealed FBI
document a few days later Burr discussed
some of that non-public information that
he had learned in the briefing with
someone via text who was that someone
their name was redacted we don't know
because it's an FBI thing it doesn't
matter what we do know is that minutes
after this call Burr logs into its
trading account and sells a hundred and
ten thousand dollars worth of stocks
that same day literally at 3 43 that
same day right after he sells his stocks
like a few hours later the White House
comes out and says that they're going to
ban people from traveling to the United
States if they've been to China in the
last 14 days soon after selling all of
his stocks Senator Burr writes a op-ed
for Fox News claiming that the U.S is
quote better prepared than ever to face
the coronavirus threat and yet Byrd
continues to sell his stocks this is his
disclosure from February of 2020 and the
guys going kind of nuts on sales all of
this whole entire rope are all sales
this guy is selling sells us up
in this time period Burr move over a
million dollars from stocks into
treasury Securities which is an
investment that is super safe during an
economic downturn but what was crazy is
that the stock market was at an all-time
high and he just sold essentially all of
his stocks and then look what happens
[Music]
and while he was downplaying the
severity of the pandemic in public in
private he was spilling the beans like
in this secret recording obtained by NPR
where Burr is telling a group of his
social club there's one thing that I can
tell you about this it is much more
aggressive than this transition than
anything that we hate
seen in recent history
it's probably more akin to the 1918
pandemic according to an investigation
by propublica Burr also passed his
private info to his brother-in-law in a
call that lasted only 50 seconds and the
very next minute his brother-in-law
called up his broker and dumped between
97 000 and 280 000 US dollars in shares
I mean if this is an insider trading I
don't know what is and yet it's
impossible to prove anything Burr
himself might even be convinced that
this wasn't insider trading and that
he's just a really smart investor and
that he did all of this based on
publicly available information and
indeed the SEC and Department of Justice
investigated this but ultimately dropped
the matter oh and fun fact Burr is like
one of three Senators who voted against
the insider trading law the stocks act
so yeah we know where he stands okay
that was kind of a longer one not all of
them are going to be that in-depth next
up we've got this monstrosity of a
document we are looking at the financial
disclosure of congressman rokana from
California
[Music]
dozens and dozens of pages and they are
effectively unreadable
[Music]
point of disclosing your financial
transactions if no one can read them
these disclosures show that since 2019
Congressman kana's family has made at
least 10 500 trades involving nearly 900
companies
quite a few okay
not a crime to make a lot of Trades
what's the deal a lot of these trades
most of these trades were done through a
trust that belongs to like his wife and
kids well it's not I don't trade at all
I'm up for a Banning trade it's my
wife's money which I have no uh actual
legal rights to but when you look at
what companies are being bought and sold
you see that of the 897 companies traded
by his family 149 of them were ones that
Kana likely had non-public information
about because of his role as a
congressman who sits on a bunch of
committees like for example he sits on
the house oversight committee which is a
committee that has directly investigated
drug prices for companies like ABV at
the same time that his wife was trading
in ABV stock you're right it was his
wife not him but you see you see that's
not okay and this wasn't the only one
the New York Times did an investigation
that found loads of instances where
kana's wife and kid we're trading in
companies that were being actively
investigated by Kana himself at the same
time examples include weapon
manufacturers like Lockheed Martin big
Pharma companies like Johnson and
Johnson yes technically it was his wife
and kids doing it not him but but come
on this feels kind of like a blurry line
but it also feels really clear like you
shouldn't be able to trade stock if your
husband is investigating the company
that you're trading stock in also these
are his children like they're not the
ones deciding what stocks they're going
to buy and sell so yeah
feels off to me but again there's no way
to prove this there's no like direct
smoking gunnish type thing that's like
this is insider trading anyway let's
move on
and then there is Congresswoman Nancy
Pelosi a Democrat from California who
served as Speaker of the House for years
speaker of the house is a role that has
major influence on what laws get through
our system Nancy Pelosi is also married
to an investor so yeah the story told in
these Financial disclosures is one of
Nancy Pelosi being married to a very
very good investor especially during
Financial turmoil in America in the two
years following the 2008 financial
crisis the Pelosi's estimated net worth
Grew From 31 million dollars to over a
hundred million dollars that's up 220
percent all while the S P 500 fell by 13
the Pelosi's also did Super well during
the pandemic seeing their net worth jump
from 106 million dollars to 171 million
dollars within like the two years of the
pandemic that's an increase of 60 during
the pandemic and I mean listen I'd like
let's be fair on this I'm sure Paul
Pelosi is a fantastic Savvy investor and
there's frankly no evidence of Foul Play
or anything insider trading here but
there doesn't have to be the very fact
that a professional investor lives in
the same home as the woman who is at the
center of the American legal and
Regulatory system
presents a major conflict of interest in
my opinion but I Know It's tricky
because I believe that people should be
able to do what they want with their
money but when we pay our lawmakers to
handle special information it feels off
to me when suddenly those lawmakers are
making bank during Financial meltdown
but it's not just these financial
meltdowns and recessions where they do
well the Pelosi sold three million
dollars worth of Google stock just a few
weeks before the doj announced that it
was suing Google for Anti-Trust reasons
like right before their stock tank
[Music]
did the pelosis know that the doj was
gonna investigate do we know no we don't
know but the timing was fishy and
besides there's plenty more examples
here like when Paul Pelosi bought
millions of dollars of Tesla stock while
his wife was passing laws that would
directly impact the value of Tesla like
major taxpayer sponsored electric car
subsidies or when he dumped millions of
dollars of Nvidia stock days before the
US government announced that it would
restrict chip makers from Trading with
China and Russia I mean the Pelosi
investor lawmaker combo has been so
successful that people have started
copying their trades
oh man Nancy Pelosi's back at it and you
know what they say you want to see how
to be successful in trading stocks just
watch what Nancy Pelosi is doing she
literally locked in a 20 game for me
she's like a meme within the investor
Community because of this and when a
journalist asked her in a press
conference about these allegations of
insider trading or if this should be
banned this was her response no I don't
know to this second one
because this is a free market and people
we're a free market economy they should
be able to participate in that and I
mean yes she's right this is a free
market economy people should be able to
do what they want with their money even
if they are civil servants who frankly
do a difficult job every day but a free
market is not a fair market if some
people especially civil servants are
operating with information that affects
the market and using that information to
get rich but again all of this is legal
like no one's breaking any rules here at
least overtly you can't prove that a law
was broken and even if you could the
only people who have the power to really
change and enforce this are the people
who are making money off of the law
being really lacks more on that in a
second but let's get back to our list
Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green once again defending her
controversial rhetoric next up we've got
Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green she's number 12 on the best
performing stock investors in our
Congress so naturally we had to take a
look on February 22nd 2022 a little over
a year ago green invested in Lockheed
Martin which is a defense contractor and
Chevron which is a giant Oil Company the
next day she puts out this tweet war and
rumors of war is incredibly profitable
and convenient okay and then the day
after that Russia invades Ukraine her
investment in a defense contractor and
an oil giant it made her a good amount
of money but who knows could have been a
whole coincidence or could have been
public information we all kind of knew
that Putin was thinking of invading it's
all technically legal and unprovable but
if you want to go down another rabbit
hole on how lawmakers profit from War
and the military-industrial complex
check out our video on who got rich off
the war in Afghanistan anyway moving on
we've got
Kepler former senator from Georgia
loffler was also in that private CDC
Senate health committee briefing that
her colleague Richard Burr attended and
look the next day she's tweeting out her
thanks for this wonderful briefing what
you've got to mention was that within
hours of the meeting she and her husband
sold off between 50 000 and a hundred
thousand dollars of stocks
and then according to her financial
disclosures in the following weeks she
sold somewhere between 1.2 and 3.1
million dollars in stocks right before
the big market crash on February 20th
like do you realize it's the same exact
thing she had a head start to get
information that none of us had about
how bad this really was and she was able
to sell all of her stuff at the right
time like Senator Burr she was
investigated for a while but nothing
ever came of it I mean it's kind of
tricky like
should Senator Kelly loffler like not
sell her stocks ever even if the economy
is melting down and we all know it like
should she be forced to hold on to her
stocks I don't think that's right either
there are some good solutions to this
and we'll get to them in a sec but let's
move on to Senator Dianne Feinstein
who was also in that room in January
2020 getting briefed on how bad the
pandemic was about to be and like others
right after the briefing she dumped a
bunch of stocks like somewhere between
1.5 and 6 million dollars man these
Senators have a lot of cash flowing
around the FBI questioned Feinstein
about this and she said that she had no
influence over this that it was her
husband who did the training and that it
was all just impeccably timed all by
himself no dinner table conversations
about today's briefing with the CDC no
Pillow Talk nothing lips sealed honey
how was your day at work today good but
I can't tell you about it because it was
a privilege briefing because you might
go off and sell all of our stocks and
avoid us losing hundreds of thousands of
dollars because the Market's probably
going to crash soon so I'm just gonna
stay totally quiet because the stocks
act says so like no I'm not saying that
Feinstein told her husband to sell
stocks I'm saying that it's absurd to
think that a husband and wife don't talk
about everything in a normal
conversation and a conversation that
would probably be laced with inadvertent
Insider information that maybe is as
benign sounding as an update on your day
or how your day at work was it's just a
natural conflict of interest and yes the
FBI backed off and closed the
investigation like they did for
everybody else okay let's get to one
more case on our list this is by no
means a comprehensive list of everyone
who has had suspicious timed trades it's
just sort of our highlights and this is
the last but not least
former Senator David Perdue who traded
2596 times in a single term the New York
Times did this great Deep dive on those
trades and found that he regularly
bought and sold stocks in companies that
fell under the Senate oversight
committee which he was on one very clear
example in all this is 2016. Purdue made
a bunch of trades in a company called
FireEye it's a cyber security company
that had oh landed a 30 million dollar
contract with the federal government it
operates out of Purdue's home state of
Georgia and most of these trades in this
company happened while he was sitting on
the cyber security panel a role that
could easily give him non-public
industry and business information about
companies like FireEye which he owns
stock in two years later
Purdue reported that he made up to
fifteen thousand dollars off of his
investment in FireEye he also traded in
a bunch of financial institutions like
JPMorgan Chase and Bank of America while
he was supposed to be overseeing them as
a member of the Senate banking Housing
and Urban Affairs committee like
conflict of interest regulating the
companies that you are personally
invested in like it's so clear we don't
I don't even have to explain any like
it's
okay well
that's it so this is all pretty
frustrating and like not right but wait
what happened to the stocks act like
where's the law remember the stocks act
remember this 2012 didn't they like pass
a law that said you're not allowed to do
this anymore kind of lately I've been
talking a lot about the the choices
facing this country
we can settle for a country that
in the economy where a shrinking number
of people do exceedingly well while a
growing number struggled to get by or we
can build an economy where everybody
gets a fair shot and everybody plays by
the same set of rules it turns out that
while the acronym is very strong the
legislation is incredibly weak it's
certainly illegal for members of
Congress to partake in insider trading
uh proving that uh is very difficult
second even if you do get caught in this
like not disclosing or sharing inside of
information the fine is laughable as a
lawmaker you don't face any real
significant penalty uh for violating the
stock act if you ultimately do
particularly the disclosure Provisions
it's theoretically supposed to be like
15 years in prison but in all of our
research not a single lawmaker has faced
any consequences even though there's
been at least 78 instances where
Congress has violated the law very
overtly you can make 10 tens of millions
of dollars with privilege information
and what's the penalty for failing to
report these purchases it's a joke it's
as low as two hundred dollars the stocks
Act was never going to prevent members
of Congress from making a few extra
dollars here and there with their
Insider information we have a free
market economy that should be able to
participate in that but here's the thing
lawmakers themselves know that this is a
problem like this is not a good look but
I'm actually for Banning stock trading
members of Congress should not be
selling uh individual stocks put it in a
blind trust trade in mutual funds but
it's not really happening anytime soon
and it's not hard to see why I mean
we're talking about Congress having to
regulate Congress this this put forth
really a bill destined to fail and the
speaker has an employed stall tactic
after stall tactic in order to kind of
keep delaying what's potentially a vote
on any bill that would ban members of
Congress from selling stocks
the tragedy in all of this to me is that
both our financial markets as well as
our entire democracy and Society are
held together by a very important and
delicate thing called trust if we expect
that to apply to our biggest
corporations and to our most successful
citizens it certainly should apply to
our elected officials especially at a
time when there's a deficit of trust
between this city and the rest of the
country a democracy can only function if
we trust the people running it and stuff
like this even if technically no rules
were broken in an evidence-based way
that undermines trust it looks really
bad in January a Republican senator who
is feeling very snarky introduced the
prevent election leaders from owning
Securities and Investments Act
which spells Pelosi the Pelosi act man
if there's one thing that our elected
officials seem to be good at it's these
acronyms that have like really fun
Optics but like don't actually do
anything what this says to me is no
nothing's going to change but it just
shows the fact that we can like create a
meme out of Nancy Pelosi and then
Dogpile over how insider trading this
all looks even if there is no wrongdoing
technically that's the problem the
Optics are the problem trust in our
democracy is delicate and the Optics
actually matter trust matters
when we erode that trust we erode our
democracy if you for example are driving
down the highway and you're going 55
miles an hour but it's a 30 mile an hour
Zone and you know you're only going to
get a five dollar ticket well you might
be driving 55 a lot
what do I do with all this paper now
hopefully recycle it paper is very very
useful for me to understand information
so I do a lot of printing anyway
um thank you all for watching today's
video I want to tell you about a couple
things number one this poster that I
designed
with a bunch of map projections on it
this is something I've thought about for
years I'm very excited to finally launch
it to the world it is a map poster about
why all maps are wrong and it is these
beautiful projections
um on this really nice paper it's just
kind of a fun art piece for map nerds if
you're into that also we have Luts and
presets if you are interested in
coloring your photos or videos you can
do that
um with our Luts and presets that is
what we use to color our stuff I should
also tell you about our community over
on patreon called The Newsroom The
Newsroom is a place where the community
supports the journalism we are doing
here we are a big operation now that is
why we were able to publish so often and
to do this kind of work we more and more
rely on the community to help support us
so thank you patrons Over The Newsroom
Newsroom members get a new video every
month that is only available to patrons
it is a behind the scenes Vlog of just
how we do what we do here in the studio
you also get access to my scripts and a
bunch of other things but more
importantly you are here a part of this
ongoing discussion we're having about
how the world works and uh uh trying to
be smarter and trying to be more
informed and trying to be critical
thinkers in this day and age of lots of
information some of it true some of it
not so thank you for being here thank
you for watching and I will talk to you
soon bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]